a
desde inicios de febrero los mexicanos
más acaudalados del norte del país
comenzaron a viajar a eeuu para
vacunarse contra el hobbit 19 un caso
muy sonado es el de san pedro garza
garcía el municipio más rico de américa
latina' ubicado en el estado fronterizo
de nuevo léon cuyos habitantes cruzan a
texas para recibir las dosis desde
entonces y hasta la fecha distintas
agencias de viaje ofrecen paquetes todo
incluido que comprenden desde el vuelo
el hospedaje y hasta el traslado a los
centros de vacunación por un costo que
ronda los 800 dólares así ahora
distintos segmentos de la población
práctica en este llamado turismo de
vacunación y es que mientras en eeuu
casi la mitad de la población ha
recibido ya al menos una primera dosis
en méxico país de más de 120 millones de
habitantes sólo 14 millones han recibido
la primera dosis de la vacuna y apenas
10 millones de mexicanos tienen ya su
esquema completo
[Música]
el gobierno peruano ha aplicado a la
población más de 2 millones de vacunas
contra el cob y 19 sin embargo muchos
consideran que el proceso es lento y
prefieren viajar a los eeuu para recibir
las dosis contra el coronavirus la
superintendencia nacional de migraciones
ha revelado que de los 4 mil 229
peruanos que viajaron a norteamérica en
febrero pasado aumentaron en marzo a 10
mil 222 mientras tanto la asociación de
viajes y turismo informó que el turismo
de vacunas traslado hacia territorio
estadounidense en el mes de abril
alrededor de 40.000 peruanos según el
gremio la alta demanda elevó los precios
en los pasajes de avión los tickets que
antes costaban entre 500 a 700 dólares
ahora se venden por más de mil dólares y
tal como nos señalan los expertos
las denuncias en algunos casos de
vacunaciones con jeringas vacías en perú
podría motivar a que más peruanos con
dinero decidan financiar el viaje para
adelantar su vacunación
[Música]
desde hace ya algunas semanas se
escuchan historias de argentinos que
viajan a eeuu a vacunarse contra el kobe
19 especialmente a ciudades donde hay
más dosis que gente que quiera ser
inoculada uno de los principales
destinos es miami el aumento de la
demanda llevó a una disparada en los
precios de los pasajes aéreos y eso
sumado las dificultades para hacerse de
dólares en argentina hace que volar a
eeuu para vacunarse sea una posibilidad
limitada a los sectores de mayor poder
adquisitivo
así este turismo de vacunas ha
despertado cierto debate algunos dicen
que es un privilegio que sólo unos pocos
pueden pagar en un contexto de escasez y
otros argumentan que es gente que con su
propio dinero afrontar los gastos y que
hace que haya una persona menos que
vacunar en argentina y además que es un
aporte a una protección más general de
la sociedad
[Música]